let's talk about what's going on with
lebron james
this guy's causing controversy he tweets
then deletes call for accountability
in the shooting death of columbus 16
year old mikaya bryant
james tweeted then deleted a picture
wednesday afternoon of the police
officer who was believed to have fatally
shot bryant writing
your next accountability the problem
well
over a little bit more they say less
than 24 hours after he tweeted
accountability
following former minneapolis officer
derek shobham being found guilty
lebron james took to social media again
to call for accountability in the
shooting of a 16 year old girl and now
deleted tweet
makaya bryant a young black girl was
shot and killed by a columbus police
officer tuesday
while yielding a knife and reportedly
attempting to stab another female
brian's death has since sparked national
outrage i got to stop here and just give
my
my respect to these journalists who
literally have a video
of the woman shoving of the 16-year-old
girl shoving a woman
against the car taking the knife and thr
pulling it back and then thrusting
forward and they say
reportedly attempting to stab wielding
should be wielding it's just yielding
yielding a knife
yeah they messed that up yeah he was
building a knife is that does that make
sense
i thought you're using a knife i thought
maybe you went to public school like me
and you
just read it wrong you read it wrong i
didn't i didn't go to high school i was
going to say something too
no it says that yeah it does yielding
are you implying that the author hope
sloop from wkyc
went to public school as well okay well
quickly how do you spell yielding
what why i uh e-l-d-i-e-i
why it's why i okay is there any shame
are you spelling it wrong
yeah not really i don't know exactly
spelling it wrong no but if you write a
completely different word than what you
meant to write it's like
right right it's okay not to know nine
times six
except if you're counting other people's
money that's right
so when you're on the block yep and
you're
facing that why doesn't lebron james
shut up
why didn't the media shut up why didn't
the country shut up
and why don't we move forward in in a
process
well we're not going to blow each other
up i wish man this is not
entertainment this is killing us
yeah why is lebron james
you know you know the problem i have is
this dude when uh all this china stuff
is going down with hong kong
he's he's the nba takes a side of china
over
the the protesters in hong kong
demanding freedom liberty respect
so this guy now has the nerve to come
out and it's just like
i don't know man he's just another look
if you take it
out the fact that it's lebron james he's
just another dude with twitter
right but it is lebron james and then
even lebron jay
if we could dial it down he understands
what he did that's why i deleted it
well and that's maybe we give him some
credit yeah
like maybe i went too crazy there
maybe we should calm down i just i don't
want any war
you know what the problem is though man
the reason he says things like this i
know he deleted that's that's true so
fine like respect for deleting it for
sure right thing to do maybe he could
say
i you know i i went too far to i would
do it you know but you don't make
mistakes but look at look what's
happening now in the wake of the guilty
verdict for derrick chauvin
all of which was correct do you think
the verdict was correct guilty on all
charges
yeah i don't think so i think well
that's guilty on all that i'm not going
to hate you but it looks like
it looked like murder to me dude yeah
but second degree murder like
manslaughter i understand
you know what i mean like i i i say like
you could make an argue from argument
from
first degree murder is like premeditated
yeah second
second is you did it and you knew you
were gonna do it or
you assaulted someone and they died and
third in manslaughter is an accident
right okay and third degree murder is
like you're acting in a depraved
negligent manner that results in death
it didn't look like an accident and it
didn't look like he meant to do it when
he got up in bed so what's in the middle
second degree it if if we all believe in
our process
if we if we love this country and those
are the rules
oh this guy just spilled beer on the
tree
would it make it worse if it was water i
could probably probably gotta get that
off the computer before you
here blow it up my problem with that
chauvin thing is that when it came out
that he was a high when uh that
that uh what's his name was high j floyd
was high on yeah yeah
fentanyl and methamphetamine yeah and
that he may have died from like heart
cardiac arrest that maybe the cop wasn't
responsible
or not not only that but that the the
prosecution's own witness said that
chauvin wasn't was legally allowed to
use a taser
and chose not to so i was questioning
whether or not like i have reasonable
doubt that
did did the cop being there do it or was
he so stressed that he would have died
on the spot anyway
i would say reasonably again well
check this out this is this i can do
that the second degree murder charge was
the felony murder rule
that if you commit felony assault
against somebody and they die
you get charged with second-degree
murder derek chovin was convicted
under the premise that his detaining of
george floyd was felony assault on
george floyd
okay that's see you're too smart for me
i mean you're really paying attention to
this well we did all i know
is i saw dude and i've been i don't know
about you guys i've had my ass beat by
the police
because that's where i come from right
yeah i saw a dude
acting in a crazy irrational manner
that's usually when police show up
but i don't expect them to be dead at
the end of it
and sometimes it does happen but i'm
looking at nine minutes
of a guy crying for his mama get off his
neck
and he did yeah well he's dead
so uh this is this is the thing i think
a lot of people
uh like i followed the trial i watched
the trial most people probably didn't
derek chauvin's knee was not
consistently on floyd's neck
he should he should have spoke for
himself yeah
like i lost it i i blanked out i have
stress
you know you should have said something
for yourself got a constitutional right
to the fifth amendment
you absolutely do and you you decided to
take that and now
i thought you said it really interesting
now he was going to jail no matter what
and this is the point
so it's not a life conviction but all
the years combined
lebron james tweeting this right we have
a whole bunch of left-wing activists
saying in no uncertain terms the only
reason chauvin was convicted is because
they burned the city down
that's not justice no it's dumb ass to
burn the city down but they did
but so figuratively like they burned out
a bunch of different buildings in the
city and smashed a bunch of windows
whenever you say they burn this idiot
down you get all these journalists being
like
false minneapolis is still a city it
still exists did we mean they burned
down a bunch of buildings calm down
you wanted to say brother yeah you said
earlier that it's not
this is an entertainment man this people
are treating this like reality tv
it and it's destroying people it's
making people
they're they're forgetting that it's
real life
and no it they live on the internet bro
yeah
that's true right but there's a swath of
america where it's really important
whether it be black america
or blue america and all in between
to some people it's really serious to
too many of us
it's a ratings grab yeah and i don't
want to be that guy
i want to be the guy that tries to bring
something
you used to work at the new york times
and where else fox and
were you the kind of guy that chased
ratings in the beginning of your career
i've never chased ratings never i just
figured if you did go
work it would do what it would do and
mostly
journalism right doesn't get any ratings
so you don't have to worry about it you
can just be in the crowd with everybody
that all changed though in the past
several years
yeah but now tell me you might get
ratings but who's doing anything that
lasts
look at anything we're talking about
anything we're watching
tell me you out there any of this stuff
are you going to show your grandchildren
one thing you're going to put in your
drawer
and go i was alive dude
the likelihood that any of these
journalists i'm doing air quotes would
show their grandchildren the things
they've done in terms of their work is
laughable
could you imagine an 80 year old guy
being like come here little billy
this is when i wrote five pictures of
brad pitt's junk
i won an internet award for that one oh
billy billy billy billy
it's gonna be in a book i'd like to i
met your grandmother when i worked at
buzzfeed
here's an article she wrote where she
said trump is literally worse than
hitler
i really don't think they're gonna be
going to their grandkids and being proud
of that stuff
i gotta say to make it all about me
um my time at the new york times my wife
kept
everything i wrote and she cut them
and she put them in these big gigantic
clip books so there's three of these
things that's what i'm saying they're
like for my great-grandchildren
and then all the stuff i wrote for the
new york times was bound in a book
and they've translated into polish and
it's coming out so i feel
like i just wrote about you know nice
guy
uh nick and easy eddie and regular
people
and that's the word of the stuff
if you're doing uh what would you call
it like human interest pieces
all of it you take human interest plus
news and you're wrapping into
something that somebody wants to read
and it's consumable
this is the thing you know if if they
were writing articles where it's like
you know jenny's genesis bakery won an
award the community is very happy
i think that's stink focus making you
feel sick
spilled the beer uh if you wrote a story
that wasn't particularly globally
consequential
but it was a good story about the
community and about the things going on
i think that's something you want to
show your kids so your grandkids but
these people at some of these news
outlets writing about brad pitt's junk
and like
you know what was there one article it
was like written by some feminists like
uh what did she call it it was like guys
with tight pants you could see their
junk
yep and it was like look at all these
guys in tight pants i'm like
congratulations that journalism degree
is paying off
but you know the problem the next guy's
in tight pants but here's the thing
journalism has become a ratings industry
you know so they they want the clicks
they want the ads well necessarily so
because the underpinnings
of it have disappeared so you now
you now got to give people what they
want so there is a responsibility of
people to
back in the day was it like one really
wealthy person would subsidize a company
to
to to study and you know report on
anything regardless of its popularity or
click-baity ness combination of factors
marketing was a big was a big play
so i think what uh correctly i don't
know yeah definitely
um reuters do you know about the history
of reuters
thompson reuters my understanding is
that the news
department was just an advertising for
like legal documents or something i
don't know the first year so i'm
probably getting it wrong
but uh i've been i've been to their
headquarters a couple times my
understanding was that they had they
have a private business and the news
outlet
advertised their business so that was
that was a big thing
these newspapers would sell ads in the
papers they'd sell the paper itself
so if you're selling the paper you're
covering your costs you're selling ads
you're making more money
and the only place to get media was in
these papers then
you want to sell as many papers as
possible when you're competing with only
a small handful of you know
very powerful and big newspapers in a
major city you got to make sure you're
reaching a certain number of people
so for a period news outlets were trying
to hit the lowest common denominator
that meant the news coverage was always
fairly close to the middle because they
didn't want to defend the left they
didn't want to offend the right
so they had to keep it fairly balanced
if they want to maximize the amount of
views they were going to get
nowadays you get infinite choices you go
online you can get your news from
anybody yeah
so now everyone's like screw it let's
just go give me what i want
they're they're they're investors who
will invest in a company that does
nothing but crazy far left of stuff
crazy far right wing stuff and they're
like i got my finger in both outlets i'm
making money i don't care
right exactly exactly you know what i
know about reuters when they built the
new reuters building in times square i
was there soup to nuts and i did a
series of stories
on the iron workers the guys that lay
the steel
and the mohawk indians have been
building the skyscrapers in new york
since 1900 wow really and there's a
whole
sort of book about there's a whole genre
about them
and i took it to them and i said did you
do you know these guys
well that was my grandpa cool well that
was my uncle what happened to him he
fell and he died
and i wrote the next chapter in that
so i don't know about reuters but i know
that i captured
the mohawk indians in the next
generation
and that's what i like to do you know
you know i think one of the problems
with news is
it doesn't need to be the biggest story
that's going to change the world
where you're going to win you're going
to be put up on stage and everyone's
going to cheer for you and clap
it just has to be good stories stories
that that are important for a variety of
reasons sometimes there's stories that
are uplifting inspire people sometimes
they're calling out bad behavior from
politicians exposing corruption
and too much of the journalism we have
today you can't even call it journalism
it's tabloid trash
it's uh um you know listicles that's why
they're coming here
they'd like to be talked somebody be
straight with me i'm sure
definitely these hundreds of thousands
of people listen they don't agree with
everything you're saying no mostly like
it was funny we had will chamberlain
here
and i'm like a little chamberlain here
yeah yeah yeah not not wilt chamberlain
not the stilt yeah yeah will chamberlain
oh oh will the attorney he will
yeah the the the conservative uh he runs
human events.com
but uh he ain't no will chamberlain i'll
tell you that right now
we disagreed and everybody in the super
chats are like tim you're wrong tim
you're wrong timmy wrong wills will's
right
but i guess so long as you know i'll
i'll tell you something
that people like when you brought up
your
your position on uh derek chovin and
then i
presented a counterpoint you said well
you know more than i do that's the kind
of attitude people expect
from what journalists are supposed to
have that if you if you have an opinion
on something you're willing to say okay
well i'll learn more about it and you
know
you call me the journalist i'm a
reporter bro reporter um
honest guy i wanna know the difference
honest guy how about that what's the
difference i do my best but
the difference between a journalist and
a reporter is a journalist
went to ivy league no i'm just i i know
i'm gonna get that
bs from a journalist can type without
looking
reporters do with fingers a a reporter
drinks with the public yeah in public
and a journalist drinks in private with
the public official
that's what so this whole thing about
journalism
it's r you're a reporter that's all you
are
yeah but these people over at cnn
they're the ones sitting there are those
guys
i mean look at cuomo's brother is cuomo
on cnn
fredo fredo fredo what a phony
dude i've been in the basement
i've been i'm coming up i'm coming up
i've been in the basement you were found
in the hamptons
on your bicycle your brother's over
there writing a book and throwing
all people and the nursing homes will
infect other old people
garbage garbage garbage
that's what we don't need sorry that's
my yeah i would 100 agree with
everything you just did
yes but that's the point these are
journalists
they complain every day about the the
insults and the threats against
journalists when they're literally the
brothers of corrupt government officials
who do bits with giant q-tips instead of
actually telling people and they lie
about having did you
ever chris me you
i've never seen you on the block you're
a rich kid
i never saw you do any reporting did you
ever go to a nursing home
because i went to the nursing homes and
i picked up
the dead bodies with the body collector
to get a look at the nursing homes did
you
i mean you're not the moralizer dude i
don't know who you are
i didn't grow up with you i didn't no
he's the guy who covered it up
come on man and i got it's not political
it's fake theater and we don't need it
do some work if you got the work i'll
believe you
if you can present it with some pizzazz
then i like you
you are preaching to the choir yes and
they're all cheering for what you're
saying
the the the new the media industry in
this country is just a bunch of people
who are
like i said what stenographers for the
state aren't that you got to pay
you know if you don't pay then you're
not going to get the highest quality
because to defend
the current reporter they got him doing
18 things a day
you know that you are a stenographer the
governor said this
you don't even got time to check out
what the governor said was right
yeah you're just pushing it i'm against
it but you do have to assume anything
trump would say was wrong
yeah that was that was the other trump's
a mess for sure
trump's a mess but there's some things
he did
that were correct like the vaccines here
but how about
how about for some reason the media
always
said he was wrong like come on a broken
clock is right twice a day if you're
saying he's wrong all the time so we got
problems well the majority of the media
did the one's wearing the blue jacket
right that's right and then the ones
wearing the red jacket said he could do
no wrong
what about us who we're the vests we're
just here in the middle they're
trying to get along but they're gone bro
it's like
no no it's the audience and it's us yeah
we're not gone that's true
we're not we just want something i'll
put it this way
the the guys in the red jackets you know
they they work for
smaller and much less ubiquitous news
outlets they're not the prominent
mainstream corporate meeting in this
country what
what are you talking about fox news fox
news is one channel
you got cbs nbc abc well unless i i
didn't say it was
everybody knows that they're mainstream
media for sure
so but reporters are mainly liberal but
i know i worked at the new york times
but i'm agreeing with you i voted for
obama twice what i'm saying is
and ronald reagan you have much fewer of
the guys in the red jackets and the guys
in the blue jackets
yeah but here's the thing how about
everybody take off the jackets and just
do what's supposed to be done
sometimes the guy in the red jacket's
wrong and you're wearing a red jacket
that's right so you're supposed to be
wearing a non-collared
shirt when you're doing what we're doing
you just
regular well now you got to call it as
you see it
based in fact but check this out you got
people like matt taibbi glenn greenwald
and michael tracy are you familiar with
those guys
matt's a friend of mine yeah exactly
those are those are the legit guys that
are wearing the vest there's very few
people actually doing journalism but
they're the guys who will come out and
say something like
you know trump was right about this that
and this but wrong about all these other
things and trump's got attitude problems
as it should be done but why is it when
you go to the new york times you go to
cnn
they're wearing the blue jacket thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time